سالفه الظلم في الرياضه وسالفه يعني
المواضيع هذه معروفه وفي كل الالعاب ما
تقدر يعني موجود هذا الشي موجود هذا اللي
بقوله هذا الشيء موجود وللاسف انه طبيعي
وعادي يعني في اي مكان في اي رياضه في اي
بطوله موجود هذا الشيء يعني ذهبيه دوره
العاب الاولمبيه سلبت من المملكه العربيه
السعوديه
صحيح طارق حامدي لاعب كراتيه صار لي
تقريبا 14 سنه اللي اذكره ان
يوم يعني دخلت النادي ودخلت في لعبه
الكارتيه هو يمكن شدن انه شي مختلف شي
غريب شيء جديد كل شيء جديد البساط الناس
الملابس كل شي والواقيات كل شي كان جديد
فهذا هذا اللي ثار فضولي مره
يعني والله انجلدت
جلد انجلدت مره ما كنت متوتر وانا داخل
العب ما كنت متوتر كثر ما كنت ضايع ضايع
ضايع مره انطق طق انطق طق بس يوم طلعت
يعني ما رضيت على نفسي صراح ما رضيت على
نفسي تدري في لعيبه كثير كثير يصله موقف
زي كذا ويوقف
[موسيقى]
خلاصو لعبه الكراتيه طول العمر
السلامه لعبه قتاليه تقليديه يه تبدا
طبعا هو اول الحزام الحزام الاصفر يعني
تبدا الحزام الاصفر بعده برتقالي اخضر
ازرق بني عند الحزام الاسود وفي فئات
اتوقع الكثير يعرفه من واحد دان الى الى ع
دان حنا اوزان تمام وفي البطولات
الرسميه لاعب واحد في كل ميزان من كل دوله
ما تقدر تلعب واحد مثلا وزنه 58 مع واحد
90 مثلا ولا 100 فاذا جيت يعني غير الرنج
هذا لا خلاص انت برا برا برا مادك تلعب
مادك تشارك في البطوله وزنك زايد راح اركض
هرول شقلب تصرف مو مشكلتنا وزنك ناقص
تحتاج تزوده كل سمنت كل حصى يشرب ماي تصرف
تصرف الزبده انك تجيب
الوزن
مثلا تقدر تلعب وتضرب بايدك وبرجلك
تايكوندو بس بالرجل في عندك مثلا زي
الجودو جيجتسو هذه اللي تسمى بالقتال
الارضي ط طحون في الارض احنا مثلا في
لعبتنا من الاشياء المتعبه صراحه ان فيها
اكسبلوسف كثير فيها انفجار قوه انفجاريه
يعني كثير تمام وفيها تحركات فيها صداع
صداع صراحه في التايكوندو
ا
مثلا الكونتاكت والهت عندهم مره قوي وسرعه
ومرونه
و دقيقتين تقريبا دقيقتين المباراه اي
وطول دقيقتين انت لازم بتشوت الجود ونفس
الشي مثلا تجلك يعني مقاومه وقوه عضليه
مره مره قويه ان طول الوقت ك سكويز عرفت
في في يعني يعتبر اتوقع شوي عيب في
الالعاب القتاليه
ان اذا ما لعبتها وانت صغير يعني خلاص انس
سسك تلعبها وانت كبير يعني لازم جسمك تشكل
عليها من انت صغير يعني اذا وصل عمرك مثلا
فوق ال ولا فوق 25 انس انس ممكن تمارسها
عادي ما عندك مشكله بس ان جدا جدا صعب انك
تكون لاعب محترف تنافس في بطولات والى
اخره جدا
صعب كانت بطوله دوره مو دوره عفوا دوري
عالمي بريمير ليج طبعا طلعت من اول دور بس
سافه مو هنا سافه في المباراه نفسها
مباراه سيئه سيئه بشكل يعني ظهرت في اسو
اسوا يعني مو القاع تحت القاع اسوا م يعني
مستحيل توصل يعني اسوا من كذا مستحيل
مستحيل وكتبت زياده وضيقت ولمت نفسي عن
مشكله عندي انا هذه يا اخي الوم نفسي
بزياده اح ان فعلا والله هالشي صار عشان
واح ان 3 شغلات برا بس يعني دائما يعني
قهم نفس
يعني صحيح يعني نظرك نظره نظرك نظره
المعتوه يعني عرفت نظره غريبه وين قال هذا
الكلام فعلا ينقال ايش جوك بعدين وين
بتوصل ل متى اكر ان كنت ولا صارت تصير حتى
من المقربين يعني سواء من الاصدقاء ولا من
العائله ولا ان ما من فائده وان ما في
مردود وان وان وان لان كرير عرفت لان كذا
لاين انت انت ماسك فيه
ف في على حسب يعني في اللي ممكن يترك
وتاثر من الكلام يتركه في اللي بالعكس انا
انا جتني كذا مره فكرت في الموضوع هذا
فعلا فكرت اني خلاص يعني اوقف الكراتيه
يعني يا اخي اللعبه في البدايات خصوصا ما
ترا مو ممتعه غثيثه يا رجل غثيثه
الاساسيات ما ادري شلون عادي انت تقدر
تلعب مثلا كوره تلعب ب طايره
سله باي شيء بادل تمام وانت مو انت مو
لاعب نادي ولا لاعب في المنتخب عادي تقدر
تلعبها يعني تستمتع فيها تاخذها فن يعني
بس ما تقدر تسوي الشي في الكراتيه لانه
ممكن تسوي حركه غلط تجيب الك اصابه لا قدر
الله ولا ولا تعور احد ولا فهمت فيها
انضباط معينه وفيها خصوصا في البدايات ما
يعني يبيلها صمله يبيلها صمله
الصراحه تجيك فعلا تجيك هذه اللحظات اللي
خلاص من متى يا رجل تمرين وبطولات وخلاص
النفسيه تقفل تصير يعني خلاص بس تبي تقعد
بالبيت ما تبي تطلع يعني مو انك تبي تفلها
تبي توقف م يعني تبي تبعد على التمرين
عشان تفلها لا بس تبي تكون السرخي هذه ما
في تمرير ما في بطولات ما في سفر ما في
قروشه بس تقعد تتنفس طالع السقف طالع
افلام على جوالك بس هذا اللي تبيه توصل
لهذه المرحله لان يعني مع كثر المعسكرات
والبطولات والتمرين خلاص يا اخي فهم تجيك
هذ
اللي والله تجيك ومع الوقت خص تصير عندك
مسؤوليه ان انت لازم
تحقق بمنجز معين مو باي منجز فعشان نسوي
ذا الشي لازم يعني تتعب وتنك وتنكد ويلعن
خيرك والامور
هذه يعني نسبه تناسب يعني كل لاعب كل لاعب
وطريقته كل لاعب يعرف شلون شلون يعني مع
الوقت مع الخبره بيعرف شلون على الاقل ما
راح يقول يحل المكله 100% بس نقول يعني
يهوم الموضوع
[موسيقى]
يعني طيب شوف دوره الالعاب الاولمبيه اللي
كانت في طوكيو اكر انها كانت اكبر بعثه
سعوديه تطلع ل دوره العاب الاولمبيه رحنا
احنا قبل اللعب اتوقع باسبوع او اقل
الامور طيبه كل شيء تمام نفسيه تمام كل
شيء كل شيء تمام
وصلت الفاينال وصلت النهائي مع خصم كان
ايراني
و واتوقع في ذاك الوقت هو كان مصنف الاول
في الوزن لعبنا الفاينال و يعني صارت
الضربه الشهيره
ووقتها ابدا ما كنت متوقع ان مو بس ما كنت
متوقع اني بنطرد ما كنت يعني ما كنت متوقع
ان كنت متوقع انه بيقوم عادي يعني اوكي
ممكن دوخه كذا يعني اوكي الضربه قويه بس
مو للدرجه انه بيغمى عليه مثلا ما انا
اتوقع ما ادري
يعني واذكر انه انشء الله بنقاله اظن اي
نقاله واحد نقاله يعني اسعاف طواري مستشفى
ما بس مو هذا اللي صار وسمعت انا ماني
متاكد صراحه سمعت
ان الطبيب ا الفريق الطبي في
البطوله قالوا ان ان جه ارتجاج في الدماغ
وشيء زي كذا لو صارلك حادث ما جاك ارتجاج
في الدماغ اوفر يعني فاي بعد ما بعد ما
شالو انا توترت يعني كل ما الوقت كان يزيد
انا تويتر صراحه قلت خفت انا ممكن صار له
شي ولا ايش دعوه اجمعوا
الحكام على اساس انه يعني تاخذون قرار
و اكيد ان كان تصويت يعني خمس
حكام ف ثلاثه صوت ان انه يفوز ان يطرد
واثنين انه يفوز مع الاغلبيه وصار الطرد
اه يا اخي غبنا يا اخي غبنا غبنا والله
يعني معليش مو اي بطوله دوره العاب
اولمبيه يا رجل اكبر بطوله اكبر محفر
رياضي في العالم ونهائي بعد يعني مو مو
مثلا والله اول دور ولا دور الانيه ولا
دور 16
ولا عدم استيعاب فهمت عدم استيعاب ما يعني
بدون مبالغه بدون مبالغه يعني من بعد
البطوله قعدت اتوقع والله بدون مبالغه
يمكن الى خمسه ست شهور مااني مستوعب يعني
من وقت المباراه يمكن قبل المباراه ما
ادري الى المباراه الى الموضوع اللي صار
الى الموقف اللي بعد المباراه مكالمه سمو
سيدي الاستقبال اللي صار
مرجعنا لقاء وتكريم سمو سيدي الى يعني خم
ست شهور قدام ما اني كذا ما ادري كنت في
حاله ما ادري ما ادري شلون اصفها ما يعني
ما استوعبت ان انا كنت في حاله كذا ما
ادري مغيب يمكن ما ادري الا بعدين يوم
طلعت منها صدق قبلت ناس مره كثير والله ما
اذكر يعني والنعم بالجميع تشرفت بالجميع
ذاك اليوم بس صدق ما اذكر ولا اي احد كنت
جدا جدا جدا منهك وجدا
تعبان ويعني من بعد البطوله ما ما حسيت
اني ارتحت صدق يعني بس زبد ان اي توقعتك
توصل هاقول م توقعك توصل نهاي توقعت ان
اخذ الذهبيه اصلا ط يعطيك العافيه طارق
والله شرف شكرا جزيلا لكم يعطي الف عافيه
تو يا
ابوي تعطيني صف الله يهينك كذا هذ نربط
الصوت والصوره بتذكر اذكر اصبر كف في
الاخير هي تكون
ايسوي
[ضحك]
ولا